coveted cases are surging at the border
with 135 detained migrants in the rio
grande
valley sector testing positive for covet
in
just the first two weeks of july and
this morning the rio grande
valley border patrol chief reports there
are actually 44 agents currently
who have tested positive there are five
of them
that are currently in the hospital their
conditions unknown
former acting director of immigration
and customs enforcement ron vitiello
joins me now
um there are so many disturbing facts
coming out and
and and details behind this on on
multiple fronts
the board of patrol agents let's just
talk about that 44 have tested positive
five are in the hospital
this could be prevented that's the most
frustrating part in all of this
it's very concerning my heart goes out
to the workforce the cbp to officers and
agents because
they can't skype their jobs you can't
patrol the border over your computer
screen they have to be
at those those locations um and and
they're exposed to people
coming from all over the world only half
of the united states is vaccinated so
the people that are coming from
these third world countries much less
vaccination
and then in that pipeline they're in
crowded conditions
at the border they're in stash houses
and agents have to interact with those
people take them into custody
the job by itself is risky and you add
the pandemic on top of that
they have to interact with these folks
from all over the world and then go back
home to their own families you can
imagine the stress that they're under
in regular conditions you put the
pandemic on top of that it's very
concerning
the number of migrants crossing our
borders i mean the numbers are just
staggering
uh and they haven't gotten any better
since this administration took control
of our country in january but here's
what i was also surprised to hear
is that when migrants are taken into
custody
border patrol doesn't actually typically
test them for covid right
off the bat so they come into this
country they may have cova they may not
they're
they're then lumped together with many
other migrants that are eventually going
to be transferred
that's when they actually test them when
they transfer them either to the health
and human services
or you know hhs custody or they're
accompanied if they're unaccompanied
children to
non-governmental organizations or if
they're part of a family unit for
transport into the u.s
they're tested then so there's a gap
there a big gap and that's why the
spread
could this be part of the root of the
problem
it is part of the problem because you
have you have this you have a
challenge with the logistics when many
many people are coming across the border
the facilities get overcrowded there's
not enough space for social distancing
and then the testing occurs like you
said
uh on the back end of their custody as
they're being transferred to
another agency as it relates to children
and some of the families and so yeah
this is
this is causing a problem for border
communities as well right they are not
equipped
um to handle all this extra traffic
and testing and isolation and
hospitalizations and so
the border communities are not not
prepared for this
uh either all right ron vitiello we
appreciate you coming on this morning
thank you very much
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now